in this video we're going to talk about
how to find the domain of a function so
a couple different approaches to finding
the domain one is if they give you the
equation so if they give you an equation
like this y equals 3 over 2x minus 1
and they say what's the domain well one
thing you want to watch out for is you
can't divide by zero you don't want the
denominator be equal to zero because
that's undefined so what you can do when
you have a fraction like this is you can
take a look at the denominator set it
equal to 0 solve and you see x equals
1/2 now we don't want X to be 1/2
because then you'd be dividing by 0 so
you could say that the domain okay is
all real numbers but X can't equal 1/2
that's one way to write it or you can
think of the number line you could say
here's 1/2
okay it's everything except for 1/2 so
what we can do if we use the interval
notation is negative infinity to
positive 1/2 curved bracket doesn't
include 1/2 Union 1/2 to positive
infinity okay so the curved bracket
doesn't include that point okay the
parenthesis so two different ways to
write this but again the main thing to
watch out for is you can't divide by
zero now another scenario that comes up
okay
is when you have a square root okay so
if you have a square root we know that
you can't take a square root of a
negative number without getting
imaginary numbers so if you take a look
at let's say this function here y equals
let's just say it's 5x minus 3
we don't want what's underneath this
radical to be negative so the way we can
find the domain in this problem is we
can take what's underneath the radical
and just make it into an inequality this
has to be greater than or equal to 0
greater than meaning positive or equal
to 0 square root of 0 is just 0 we don't
want it to be less than 0 that would be
negative if we can't take the square
root of a negative without getting
imaginary numbers so if we're looking at
the domain here
we can solve this and say okay five X is
greater than equal to three okay
divided by 5 so X has to be greater than
or equal to 3/5 okay so that's one way
to write it so it's all real numbers
that are greater than equal to 3/5 or if
you want to use the interval notation
3/5 to infinity sometimes I like to draw
this on the number line just to
visualize it so 3/5 including 3/5 to
infinity so we think about going from
low to high or left to right and we can
write our interval that way so two
things to pay attention for when you're
looking at the domain don't you can't
divide by zero and you don't want to
take the square root of a negative
numbers so you just make an inequality
and set whatever is underneath the
radical greater than equal to 0 this is
for even roots so square roots fourth
roots six roots like that you can take
the odd root of a negative number like
the cube root of negative 27 that's okay
that's just going to be negative 3 but
we can't take the even root of a
negative so that's how we would approach
that one now just another note about
domain let's say you're given instead of
the equation you're given the graph okay
so you're giving the graph sometimes
students struggle a little bit with
finding the domain so say for example
you know this is your graph and let's
just say that it looks like this one two
okay right there this is the x-axis this
is the y-axis so what you can think
about is you can think about domain is
what the x-values can be and the range
are what the y-values can be what I do
is just like I just did there is you
take a vertical line usually like your
mark or your pencil like this you scan
from left to right okay from negative to
positive and you can see there's no
points on the graph here at zero at one
not until we get to two and Beyond are
there you know points on the graph right
so that means that the domain has to be
X is greater than or equal to two so you
could say X is greater than equal to two
or if you are using the interval
notation from two to infinity now the
range this is going down towards
negative infinity up towards positive
infinity the range would be all real
numbers but in this last thing we were
just talk
about the domain so we're thinking about
going from left to right like that
okay so this has just been a little
overview about how to find the domain
whether you're given an equation or
you're given a graph so review it again
if you need to and I'll see you in the
next video